sipa lise vachon
non je devrais pas n'ont alors eu un
oreiller oui deux non
alors oui oui des gens parlant cher
monsieur mes lauriers roses qu'il est à
moi c'est la première fois que je dors
sur le palier alors je ne suis pas au
courant des habitudes de ces nouveaux de
catane
oui chalabi de cet immeuble que depuis
deux jours ont changé mais enchantés
aussi enchanté qu'est ce qui vous amène
un différend avec ma femme c'est pareil
mais nous aussi même ça alors monsieur
je vous fais juge
j'allais pas me coucher je la trouve
complètement con travers du lit non mais
vous vous rendez compte
mais quel culot la colère m'a pris la
moutarde me monte au nez ou saga les
monter la moutarde au nez mais c'est pas
la place pour la moue d'armor
je suis hurler basse avec des pics et
j'ai fais pas ça vous avez bien fait je
fais pas ça y'a pas envoyé dire que
l'autorité
non mais dis donc deux fois non j'ai pas
le temps l'espoir peu de places toit 10
et 11 en 5 1 je vais coucher sur le
palier grâce médicale autorités ça n'a
pas traîné elle s'élevait est allé se
coucher sur un divan non elle s'est
levée elle m'a poussée sur le palier
d'ailleurs alors lâché ricaner messager
fait il valoir
et je l'insulté grosses bêtes
quelle autorité monsieur à la fouille et
la police de son pays noir elle a tiré
son mouchoir elle a pleuré à noël
attirer ces clés la ferme et la feria et
vous monsieur coucher se voit sur le
palier 1
tous les vendredis monsieur le jeudi
souvent le mercredi parfois le mardi
c'est grave mais jamais lundi pourquoi
l'ana chez sa mère et le fond de ma vie
particulièrement oui j'ai un banquet à
l'amicale des anciens jeunes alors si je
range après 11 heures
je ne rentre pas assez ça ils ferment
alors je prends une valise je mets
dedans mon oreiller mon pyjama
bush pays je me disais tu vis dans
l'ascenseur et je me couche directement
sur le palier à johnson même pas avant
elle le sait que je suis là non car je
ne me fait pas beau je l'invite bonne
nuit pour qu'à l'autorité et pourra me
supplier de rentrer vous je retrouvais
pas tardé attendait peut-être qu elle
supplie on savait qu'un genre isuppli
plus monsieur à bas par contre la mienne
tout à l'heure à 8 heures du matin
j'allais la voir elle va bien l'ouvrir à
sa porte
allah vous supplier de rentrée non non
non non elle va me dire de lui faire son
petit déjeuner parce que c'est vous qui
avez depuis jeudi
tous les matins je le fais exprès ces
fonds lui même jour l'inventaire annuel
et couchez vous êtes debout bull a
dominé la russe elle est vexé vous savez
on a là une trouve plus ses mots elle
veut pas en fermant le si la belle nous
fait qu a fait ses preuves miel mienne
qu'est ce que vous répondez à sa manche
paul
n'est ce pas un peu amer monsieur mais
les femmes sont les dresser les sur les
greens saut moi j'ai passé la nuit enfin
j'ai dressé
on l'a enfin les dresser oui on voit ça
c'est dresser tout ça on n'est pas des
sauvages jour oui regardez la télévision
monsieur un bon sujet j'arrive j'avais
fait les connaisseuses étant encore en
charentaises
j'ai mon cabas mon cas - mon caddie
j'arrive à n'ai pas fait la russie c'est
pas vrai et sastre elle ne fait ce geste
est vulgaire qui veut dire ta bouche bb
os
je répète ma foi dans les urnes non
c'est moi comment son geste obscène
oui c'est pas beau mais elle ajoute oui
puis pouf pouf pouya vous à son époux y
assemble sont des doubles s'arrête a
pris l'habitude mais ouais j'ai fonce à
l'office solana
j'ai attrapé la balle on vous la fait
porter à sa peau quelle horreur la
l'attendait là lâche non la lavette
sébile tablions dirigé rien ni un à l'ap
a répondu moi je ne fais pas la
vaisselle
ah ça non je ne sais pas la vaisselle
sam abîme les mains et après je ne peux
plus coudre
parce qu'il ne sait pas qu un non on ne
sait pas mettre le couvert mais par
contre la cuisine alors ça la cuisine
elle l'a fait vraiment très mal à tous
mes amis me le dit chez toi c'est des
gars je n'irai pas et pour ça la cuisine
non non non non non non non non non non
non non non elle a son salon moi j'ai ma
guise
or à la son salon son piano son chien
son ca et son fils au d'un nom moi j'ai
ma cuisine vous avez rencontré une fois
elle n'a fait un chantier encore chaud
et ça ne retarde pour ma lessive
ah mais oui mais ça les fans ne veulent
pas le comprendre nous on travaille
toute la semaine on a clos dimanche pour
l'aller vous connaissez nous devenons je
me sens je les hais les dimanches
monsieur le matin j'ai le jardin et le
poulet rigaux j'ai le gazon l'après midi
monsieur je fais ma lessive les couleurs
d'un côté le blanc de l'autre après ceci
dubois elle vous fait le soir puissiez
bah ouais mais ça les femmes
s'enveloppent la mienne avant d'être
mari elle travailla maintenant le
travail mais ma jumelle travailler ma
femme elle était mannequin
ah bon chez balmain chez courrèges
sheholli da à oui alors sans doute
est-ce une personne qui a un certain
physique pour sa mise charcuterie wii
est très appétissant c'est une femme qui
n'a jamais ouvert une porte avec sa main
je la connais je les croisais dans
l'escalier roulait pas pu la croiser ah
bon elle est incroyable
mais c'est pourtant vrai j'ai dû
redescendre 2 et a annoncé cette annonce
et elle s'assit new moon avec ses
petites socquettes innover c'est cette
personne qui porte son collier
horizontalement
c'est la seule femme au monde qui peut
compter ses pairs mon argent s qui l'a
tué c'est la robe maxi pourquoi on
dirait une course en sac d'envoyer vos
la mienne at elle ensuite toute autre
branche de l'industrie
elle était et ses yeux gérard c'est très
rare était chez peugeot au nom giro di
genova drôle ou pas du tout non au tce
chocottes
la prothèse dentaire linon oui elle
présente les modèles elle a un très très
bon physique pour ça va pas alors fall
et de la voix par donges animal
s'appelle jeanine oui je l'appelle man
in ses chars et vous moi je m'appelle
coco assez charmant aucune envie la
corrida concours vous appeler jacques
vabre du tout non pas du tout non non
non elle m'appelle coco parce que je
suis colonel en génie oh non pas de
génie de carrière et vous
je suis pdg monsieur pardon j'ai pdj
dans pardonnez moi je n'avais pas
entendu toutes les lettres
catégorie et j'ai des usines
oui j'ai 18 et g20 secrétaire et demain
en arrivant au bureau
s'il se permet un petit peu à la vie est
un zoo harragas mais je crois bien
longtemps bon allez voir ce ne pas
l'aimer si je suis catholique